how was it um touring with MGK who's  another amazing performer he thought so  he's dope that had to be that's a  [ __ ] crazy tour if we just think  about the historical context of a RJ MGK  Young Thug tour so this was that 2019  what's up yeah  yeah that was real dope it was fun and  you know we got into a lot yeah you know  he's a wild boy I mean I know he has a  song called another we ain't get into  nothing too bad [ __ ] like that like it's  just typical tour [ __ ] right getting  [ __ ] up going to different city going  to different states yeah you know being  on the road and you know and you know  [ __ ] missing home and things like that  just regular you know just turning up  and [ __ ] just giving our  a little energy you know what I'm saying  given 132 in every city in every state  so that's pretty much what a big like